We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2, David P..
And in this voicemail, there's a question
asked about is someone coming up to you without
a mask?
An attack, in a sense.
And if you are in a stand your ground state,
could you shoot such a person?
Take a listen to this.
Yes.
Hi, this is Anton in Hawaii.
Really curious about those states that have
stand your ground laws.
So if you are outside and somebody and you're
in a mask and somebody comes up to you that's
not wearing a mask.
Why not your shooter?
That's just my question.
My thought today.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Listen, I understand the idea.
The idea is we've got a contagious disease.
It's spreading virally because it is a virus
and people should be protecting it themselves
and each other by wearing masks.
If someone comes up with you up to you with
no mask.
If they cough on you, that potentially puts
your life in danger in the same way than if
they came up holding a gun and pointing it
at you.
I get the idea.
I don't believe that even in states with Stand
Your Ground, you would get away with shooting
someone who is coming up to you without a
mask.
I don't recommend you do it.
If you really have questions about it, consult
law enforcement and a lawyer.
But it sounds like a very, very bad idea.
I understand the sentiment.
I understand the idea, but it is not something
that I would imagine anyone is going to get
away with.
On today's bonus show, we will talk about
Iran reportedly launching its first military
satellite as Donald Trump continues to make
threats.
We will talk about Mitch McConnell saying,
I wouldn't count on any further coronavirus
aid because of the debt.
And we will talk about a police department
testing pandemic drones, which could sense
fevers and coughing fevers and coughing.
All of those stories on today's bonus show.
Don't miss it.
Become a member at joint Patman dot com and
you will get instant access.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.